if you want to be inspired empowered and
I feel like laughing and then tune in to
total divas it is true when it says you
kind of grow out of something and Nikki
and I realized this year that you know
what it is time to say goodbye to total
divas The Bella Twins announcing on
their podcast that they are not
returning to total divas after eight
seasons but they will continue with her
spin-off total Bella's what people don't
realize is we filmed all year long so
when other people would get breaks from
the reality cameras brie and I would be
filming a season of Bella's and then we
go straight into divas the pair says
they will still make appearances on the
show but revealed what went into the
decision-making process my thing is I'm
a mom and I don't want birdie to grow up
in front of the cameras brenneke it with
the public break up with John Cena that
took at all I'm not sure we should go
through with this that just showed me
that when you have hard times in life
and you keep filming it's just you know
it's really hard on someone mentally we
had to let go of one show just to keep
sanity when I think to what people don't
realize is we have to live our lives
twice that was exhausting the news comes
just after Nikki announced her
retirement from the WWE I really AM
ready to hang up the Jersey but she does
seem focused on her personal life with
her former Dancing with the Stars
partner Artem I feel like the first time
ever I'm focusing on me it's crazy I
never in my life would have thought that
like I would have had a lot in common
with the Russian I feel like it I'm at
that age where I'm discovering who I
really am what do I want out of life and
just like independence and I'm enjoying
it mocking allies it's scary and you
have these moments of like what am i
doing and you have fear but I just I
kind of am liking the challenge and that
beer because it's just forcing to be out
of my comfort zone it's kind of like
dancing
[Music]
[Applause]